do you see Psychiatry as fundamentally a
study of the human mind and not just the
set of tools for treating psychological
maladies absolutely I think Psychiatry
is our best way to understand who we are
as people I mean it looks at our biology
you know how does our brain work how
does it connect the parts with one
another how does the chemistry in it
work it's a very foundational aspects of
who we are and then it manifests as
psychology what do we think what do we
feel what are our strivings what are our
fears so yeah I think Psychiatry
provides
tools that we can use to help each other
but those tools come through it being a
discipline of understanding
so with every patient you see with every
mind you explore are you picking up a
deeper understanding of the human mind
I think I'm trying to I think we should
learn we should be able to take
something away from everything we do you
know every interaction to some small
degree every conversation it doesn't
have to be a patient just anywhere at
Starbucks getting a coffee you can learn
something from that little experience
yeah even if you just reinforce sort of
gentle kindness and gratitude and and
decent human interaction there's a
reinforcement of that that even if we
don't take away memories or lessons so
to speak we can reinforce who we choose
to be
so understanding ourselves from those
interactions too not just the general
sort of philosophical human mind but
understanding our own mind
introspect on how our own mind works yes
everything we understand about anyone or
anything else is coming through here
right so yeah so we're understanding
others where we're also understanding
ourselves it's all feeding
through US yeah yeah but it's a tricky
thing to step away and look at your mind
and understand that it's just a machine
and you can kind of control the way the
machine processes the external
environment and the way that machine
converts the things it perceives into
actual emotions like how it interprets
the things it perceives you just sort of
step away and analyze it in that way and
then you can control it you can you can
oil the machine you can control how it
actually interprets the Perceptions in
order to generate positive emotions and
be like a what is it like a mechanic
for the for the gears in the machine
I mean I think to some degree to some
degree of it the difference I think at
least is I understand I think of
machines as not being inscrutable right
that that if there's enough study
there's enough Acumen applied that we
can understand whatever it is we're
trying to to figure out whereas part of
understanding ourselves is understanding
that there are things we can't
understand and I think that's that's
indispensably important to health and
happiness and also to having enough
humility to see how people can be
different from us how we can be
different from ourselves at times so
knowing that we don't know a lot and
having some idea of what that might be I
think is an indispensable part of the
process which I think is different from
machines I think yeah the machines
you're basically saying machines
generally because they're engineered
from a design they're usually going to
be simpler therefore understandable and
you're saying the complexity of the
human mind is uh
at least from our perspective nearly
infinite
is there a meta phenomena what sometimes
gets described as sort of levels of
emergence where at increasing levels of
complexity you have novelty evolved that
you that you can't predict from from
lower levels of complexity like for
example atoms to molecules you know it's
just one example I I think
neurons to Consciousness Consciousness
to culture right that there are meta
phenomena that separate from the
phenomenon from the phenomena underneath
of them and and therefore by adding an
entire aspect of novelty so I I think we
are
I mean I really think this is true that
we are all infinitely fascinating
because of these levels of emergence of
novelty that are inscrutable because you
can't predict from one level to the next
or understand fully are what make us and
not just us but I think sentient
creatures right human beings right but
sentient creatures inestimably more
interesting than than creatures that
aren't as sentient and and I don't know
I think when when we think about machine
learning and artificial intelligence I
think it's that that we're trying to
create levels of emergence that now we
don't fully understand anymore which I
guess is both exciting and maybe scary
too
yeah so he started the physics of atoms
uh quantum mechanics going to chemistry
going to biology
from the biology you have the functional
phenomena especially as manifested in
the human brain and then multiple brains
connecting together through
Consciousness intelligence creates
civilizations it's pretty interesting
where do you think the magic is at which
layer of the cake every layer because
every time you emerge from one thing to
another I see it as an analog like the
concept of the dialectic right where I
think it was Hegel right who who
realized
um hey when you when you have like thing
a and thing B and they're complicated
and they come together you know you
don't get a hybrid of A and B right you
know you you end up getting something
that's new that's novel and and I think
that describes to some degree that like
what emergence is except there's
there's a whole new and it's Universe of
novelty right that that comes at each
layer of emergence that allows infinite
possibilities that weren't possible
before and I think that's why we're so
complicated that we're our functional
Neuroscience right which I think is
psychology right our ability to think
about ourselves about others to be
reflective is sitting on top of so many
layers of emergence like the idea of
standing on the shoulders of giants that
we're you know each of us our
Consciousness is standing on the
shoulder of a giant of many many many
levels of emergence of novelty so many
of which we don't understand I mean
about subatomic particles everything
that that quantum physics means you know
when when does time become important
right as opposed to things happening
outside of time and outside of space
when do we slot into one temporal
perspective and then the complexity just
I think grows and grows and grows yeah
the interesting word he uses novelty
if true this really blows my mind in
some uh either shallow or deep sense it
is true I'm trying to figure that out I
don't know if you know something about
cellular automata is this very simple
mathematical objects where you have
rules that govern each individual little
cell and they interact locally and that
you know you understand the very simple
operation of those individual cells but
add another layer of abstraction when
you just kind of zoom out with blurry
vision these uh meta objects starts
appearing that function you could build
a touring machine whether you can build
an arbitrary complexity of of compute of
uh of computation on top of this kind of
very simple object yes it's an
interesting question whether
that was always there
the atoms
somehow know about love right like about
Consciousness
about war and violence and evil and hate
and all that that's already Laden in the
possibility of that the capacity for
that it's already in the atoms it's
already in the physics it's already in
them
in in all the different chemistry and it
builds up and it's like even the origin
of life
still a mystery that's that's known
that's in the physics that's known to
the universe the basic uh background
physics in the universe
because if that's not the case
where does that come from where's that
magic
and how many layers can the cake
possibly have how many are we gonna keep
building if it's all if there's if we're
constantly through this process of
abstraction of adding a layer to the
cake adding novel things
like where's the ceiling
as we expand out into the cosmos if we
successfully can do that we're going to
keep building like more miraculous
complex objects and then the brain is
just like a middle layer
thing we tend to think of ourselves as
truly truly special manifestations of
what's possible in the universe but
maybe we're just like the basic like
tiny building block of something much
much bigger we're in the early days of
being a brick and a very large building
sure look I think that's entirely
possible I mean I think the only
emergent thing so to speak that that we
build is culture right the aggregation
of us so you have individual human Minds
which are entirely unique I mean even
the fact that time is different for you
and me right it may be by Pico seconds
right but we can engage because our our
perceptions of time are parallel enough
they're close enough right that we can
share a reality right but we're all
living in a different dimension of time
right I mean we know that right so we're
unique in that way and then the Unique
Individuals that we are just like the
cells right start to create not just one
thing not just a culture but culture on
top of our individuality right there are
our uniqueness our even dimensional
uniqueness of of time and experience and
and Consciousness so we create cultures
on top of us but what could be Beyond
culture right and and what is different
from us either on underlying levels like
you know like quantum physics or
chemistry or biology or entirely
different and unconceived I think is
it's an immense question and I think
it's one that should create humility in
us right that look look how much we
don't know and then how Reckless we are
with ourselves with our Resources with
with human life and and I think there
it's I I it's important to say when you
think about how entropy rules
the universe around us I mean how over
selected are we how many not just
hundreds or thousands of times but how
many millions of times does there have
to be a selection Branch point before we
get into a sort of Eddie pool of counter
entropy right where you can begin to
create
right which which I think is why you say
okay the the atoms know about love right
the the the fact that anything is being
created right means there's this over
selection for counter entropy where
there can be a building of Greater
complexity of ultimately of novelty and
we don't often think about that of of
how far removed we are maybe light years
so to speak uh from any other location
temporally physically in the universe
where this could happen and we don't
think about what does that
mean everything that you said love
everything is uh uh counter entropy goes
against the way
uh the basic physics of the universe so
maybe actually the atoms really don't
like what we're doing they want us to
stop they've been trying really hard to
stop and despite that we somehow uh
started this whole bacteria thing for
for like a billion years and now we're
hearing it I think of it kind of the
other way I don't think there's any
purpose to purposelessness right so so
why would anything be here if we if the
drive weren't towards
creativity right if a drive warrant
towards those subatomic particles not
being nothingness that blips in and out
of existence right like we think is
going on in empty space you know for
light years upon light years right but
is
is there a design either natural or
intentional for
um a schema right a scenario that allows
for the incredibly rare but not
non-existent Eddie pool of counter
entropy where good can happen right
where creativity can happen where
ultimately something can grow something
novel can happen there's no novelty in
the vastness of space even though
there's not nothing there there's
novelty here because I think the the
layers of uh of emergence start stacking
very very very high when we're in the
place of counter entropy which then
could provide even thoughts about like
good and evil right the idea that
creating that preserving is good right
it's what we build upon is how we get to
the Eddie pool of counter entropy right
so then destruction is not good what
what good comes of aggression and
destruction right you know unless we're
protecting we can think of of outlying
cases but you think in general concepts
right destruction destroys it brings us
towards a state of entropy towards a
state of nothingness whereas goodness
commonality
um collaboration right
nurturing right brings
novelty it brings new existence into the
universe and I think we don't we don't
think about that we're in the middle of
something so vast and built on top of so
many layers and I think it leads us to
be Cavalier you know with with human
life including often our own
so you think this there's a underlying
creative force of the universe that uh
that might even have a kind of
built-in morality to it where
creating is better than destroying
and then that somehow maps on onto our
society where we kind of try to figure
out what that actually means in terms of
Good and Evil so there that's some
something is there like that but it's
like but it has to be
it's like so nice it's so perfect
because it's rare
it's sufficiently rare where we have our
own space like you can like close the
door and it's like I need to be alone
right now as our human civilization to
work on my thing so it's sufficiently
rare that there's not other alien
civilizations they're just like
constantly knocking on our door
destroying us
um but it still exists that's weird
right right it's so fantastically
improbable yeah that I think we should
be very respectful of it and I think you
said there's a creative force that
values creativity yes things to be well
sure if it's a creative Force right it's
existence its ability to exist and to
create
comes from something other than entropy
right something other than so much
dispersion that there's nothingness
right so so the creative force will
value
the sanctity of things right you know
keeping things together not destroying
things right building novelty including
novelty of knowledge novelty of
sentience I mean it fits with the idea
that we're not nothing that that's
incredibly improbable and that there are
these many many layers of emergence that
we're standing upon and I think it tells
us something that we're not doing
ourselves a service to ignore right it's
not just a jump to saying oh there's a
religious answer to everything he says
no it's saying
science isn't a God either right so if
we if we if we think of science as a
tool and not as an endpoint in and of
itself what is the science telling us
like I remember showing up at medical
school and it really is true I mean I
knew so little about the human body I'd
only been in hospitals to visit people
I'd taken pre-med classes but sort of
intensely at once after I didn't take
any and I was working in business I I
knew next to nothing and and I had this
idea that was so naive in retrospect
that I was going to learn so much right
I was going to answer these questions
because I was going what's going on in
the body what are these organs doing
what are these cells and what I learned
was
there was so much more that was amazing
and mysterious and seemingly impossible
like even how a cell functions right
like what is going on inside of a cell
the transport mechanisms and energy
functions and diffusion functions and
then you can go down to smaller levels
than that but when you come back out and
you say how all those cells make a
kidney it's not
explanatory you know I remember asking
the OB who had delivered my first child
right I was so amazed and I asked him
like what do you think like what do you
know you do this right you're seeing
this life created and you know and his
thought was nothing but I just marvel
you know I mean I get to do this but I
just marvel at it and I think the more
we know
about us the more we respectfully Marvel
and we should do that we should
proactively Marvel at every aspect
at every layer
that were the novelty emerges
yes we'd be a lot less likely to say hey
I don't like you because of something
whatever it is you know race religion
culture sexuality gender identity
whatever it is you know oh I want to say
I want rights that you don't have right
or I want what you have right I mean
there's so much of this and I understand
it's driven by scarcity and by human
insecurity and envy and all of these
things that I think could drive us
towards destruction but all of that
recklessness comes from
not having this initial appreciation and
respect that you're referring to and
just marveling at like wow okay we're
here that's amazing let's start with
that